to then giving up offensive rebounds and
no bigger offensive rebound
than the one by j mark j michael green
on that last possession
[Applause]
nuggets with 19 second chance points
they are all smiles you think about
michael malone's nuggets and their run
in the bubble last year remember they
were down 3-1
twice and ended up winning those first
two series against utah and then
the clippers possessions again by the
trail blazers allowed the nuggets
to creep back in the game and once the
momentum was going ba
there's no holding back and portland
couldn't respond couldn't make shots
like they did
there's an embrace two coaches terry
stotts michael malone
the portland trailblazers will have been
eliminated four
of the last five years in the first
round and that is it
nicola yokic and the denver nuggets
put the blazers away in six they win
on the road and the former teammates who
have battled all series long
final embrace as the nuggets win this
one by eleven
and one piece to the puzzle is set in
the bottom half of that bracket denver
now awaits
phoenix or los angeles the suns have a
chance
to eliminate the lakers tonight lakers
trying to survive
seven in phoenix i mean once again you
just
i feel for it i've been in a situation
where you play your heart out and you
lose but again dame
miller just not like anybody else
there's certain players that when they
lose
your heart just goes out for them
because you know what they put in and
again
that's not taking away anything from his
teammates but
special players touches and only come
along so often and dame lillard is one
of them
and unfortunately he's not able to
continue a playoff in championship type
of run
once again
[Applause]
and this game takes 28 points 13 assists
just one late field goal in the fourth
quarter phenomenal
effort historic performance in game five
but it's another first round loss
for damian lillard and the portland
trailblazers
a lot of questions a lot of important
decisions that have to be made
because you've been kind of stuck a
little bit in this in between
states now injuries played their role
that college you know
you know so it's not all attributed to
maybe continuity with the team in
regards to players sometimes
but they do have to
figure some things out this offseason
rip city
nicole is kind enough to join us after
he hugged everybody on that sideline
nicola that was some series you guys had
some
finishing kick here tonight in your mind
what was the key that got it turned
around late in that third quarter
uh i mean it was uh we mean we made some
big stops and we scored a basket you
know i think in the in the clutch then
no matter how good or bad defensively
are if you make stop you're a good
question so
we we need it we need the stops we made
stuff we made
uh basket uh j mike grabbed couple
offers and rebounds
he was amazing for us so uh aaron
brother made it a corner three
uh so it was a team effort
nicola you this is jimmy jackson the
team has been
asked the same question without jamal
murray how far can you go without jabal
murray how far can you go
in this portland series you're able to
close it out on the road
what does that say about the current
roster right now the nuggets
i mean nobody can can uh can take the
fight
out of us you know we can just go out
there and fight and that's what we
that's what we're doing you know so uh
we're never we're never gonna quit
there's a quit is no not in our
vocabulary so
we're just gonna go out there and fight
every game congratulations nicola
phenomenal effort tonight we'll see in
round two partner i think i think
36 points for nicole